الخوف ام المرض النسيان ام زلات اللسان
الصحه او التقدم في السن
هل فعلا تلك اسباب دفعت الى تاخر ترشح
بايدن بين بايدن وترامب هكذا ظلت الانظار
مؤخرا تاره تتجه نحو محاكمه ترامب وتاره
نحو جو بايدن منافسه الغائب الحاضر عن
الانتخابات الامريكيه على الاقل حتى
اللحظه
جديد بايدن اعلان خطف فيه الاضواء من
محاكمه ترامب حين قال في مقابله مع برنامج
تودي على شبكه ام بي سي انه يخطط لترشيح
نفسه لكنه ليس مستعدا للاعلان عن ذلك
رسميا
الرئيس الحالي بايدن صاحب الثمانين عاما
يواجه تحديات كثيره قد تكون هي التي منعت
اعلانه الترشح اولها تقدمه في السن فلو
ترشح فعليا انتخابات 2024 فسيكون اكبر
مرشح على الاطلاق في تاريخ الانتخابات ولو
فاز سيحافظ بلا شك على منصب الرئيس الاكبر
سنا في تاريخ امريكا
سبب اخر اثار الجدل هل فعلا صحه بايدن
تسمح له بالاستمرار في قياده امريكا
فمؤخرا اعلن رسميا عن ازاله ورم سرطاني
منه وقبل ذلك ترى التساؤلات كثيره حول
زلاته في الخطابات ونسيانه حتى اسم نائبته
وبالعوده الى ترامب يبقى دوما صراع
الرئاسه مختلفه فالرئيس السابق لم يتوانى
لحظه في استغلال محاكمته لجمع تبرعات
لحملته وتوظيفها في انتخابات مقبله تكون
فيها الكفه راجحه لصالحه بعض المراقبين
قالوا ان رهبه ترامب واستغلاله كل شيء
لخدمه ترشحه قد يكونان واحدا من الاسباب
التي وترت حياه بايدن واخرت اعلانه الترشح
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات